well josh 13 the musical is so cute i
kept thinking when i was watching i was
like well i wish my life as a 13 year
old was just breaking out into song and
dance i think it would make it a little
more fun mine was kind of was it yeah a
little bit but i you know i went to
performing arts high school and i
remember going from like a very normal
elementary school into this place where
like people were singing and doing
cartwheels down the hallway i was like i
think i found my tribe
[Applause]
you got something in your nose
so
i want it
well did you consider asking me first
i'd like to be in charge of the items in
my nose if you don't mind i love it i
was gonna say theater people are the
best you know performers i should say
are are the best um it's such a sweet
story how did this come about for you
because you do play a rabbi in it right
i do okay i i play uh evan our sort of
lead character uh i play hitch rabbi and
i i love the idea that we were sort of
redefining this idea of sort of like the
stately stoic sort of long bearded uh
religious leader in this kind of cool
millennial rabbi who's trying to help
this kid who very clearly is going
through it right his parents are
recently divorced he's completely
uprooted his life from new york city to
indiana so a bit of a culture shock i'm
sure
and he's just trying to help him
throughout this process because bar
mitzvahs are wonderful and weird and
challenging and i think my character
really knows that
one second sorry
hello
yeah
yeah yeah hold on it's god he wants his
language back
you grew up in front of the cameras too
you were acting at a very young age to
now take a step back and watch all these
kids do it and as you're playing a rabbi
was that kind of a full circle moment oh
my gosh completely i remember watching
sort of the final big song and i'm
sitting there with deborah messing and
ria pearlman and peter herman and we're
watching these kids like we're literally
in this church and the kids stand up and
i i did say church and i am right
even though it's about a bar mitzvah
we watch these kids like stand up and
they are belting out this gorgeous song
and i remember looking at the other
actors and be like are you gonna go
cause i'm going it's happening it's bad
like i was like we were just it's so
moving i bet it's even more emotional
because you you're a dad now too right
you're like please yeah oh my god these
kids like where are they coming from
right it's all over now it's all over
now that i have a kid i'm like you're
crying at commercials crying in the club
it's bad what does that mean that i
don't have a kid and i'm doing that
already you know i'm like watching tv
just wait just wait you haven't been
here since you were five but if it took
a divorce to get you to come back maybe
it's a good thing mom well i look at the
bright side
what is there to do around here uh
obviously so much of this story is about
being 13 and like this coming of age
what was 13 year old josh like
oh man cholesterol high you know i was a
heavy boy you know i was thicker than
most sure same actually honestly i mean
it yeah um you know it was i remember my
bar mitzvah specifically actually being
a pretty wonderful event i was lucky my
my one of my best friends his dad is a
rabbi shout out rabbi henry schreiber
and i i called him when i got this part
and i said can you tell me any nuance or
anything to think about in playing this
role and he said listen it's all about
doing something that's really
challenging at a young age with grace
and that's what i try to employ and
teach my my young sort of students when
they're going through hebrew school and
doing this thing where you're like why
do i have to learn this now wow i feel
like you also
describe what it could be like to be a
child actor that's how you kind of
navigate that world did you apply that
into your career
i don't know if i knew it at the time
that i was applying it but you know i
was so lucky to have a great mom who was
like really my protector throughout that
time so i really had a true north and if
you read my book uh happy people are
annoying
uh you know i i sort of talk about how
certainly during you know 18 through 21
i went through a total knucklehead phase
where i had to sew my wild oats sure
so this was all just to get jesse a new
tinder profile pic yes
good luck with that
all right so josh you um you posted
support for your friend jeanette mccurdy
this week which by the way so did nicki
minaj i don't know if you saw that no i
didn't yes on queen radio she kind of
praised jeanette saying that a lot of
her fans will be inspired by this book
you know especially the ones that have
been writing with her for so long uh you
know what did you make of her i don't
know sharing her truth in this way in
this book i just think it's incredibly
brave yeah and for her to do it in a way
you know she has this beautifully like
biting comedic voice and this thoughtful
way of expressing her journey and her
pain and her challenge and i just honor
her in that because it takes a lot of
guts but i also know sort of the power
that when you do get vulnerable and
share your story how so many people can
see themselves in it and find a little
bit of a reprieve so i'm i'm just really
proud of her did you see parts of
yourself and her story at all because
obviously you guys have this shared
unique experience of working at such a
young age i think so i mean
to be honest and and what i wrote about
in my book was yeah navigating sort of
growing up in in the public eye and that
you're not always sort of afforded the
opportunity
to stumble in a safe way that you would
be if you were just having a normal kid
experience that's true yeah extra
pressure a lot of other circumstance so
yeah i think so i mean you have a lot of
important jobs you're juggling right
between fatherhood and your career in
fact as much as we love you in this
movie i love to see you on how i met
your father thank you i love the
relationship with you and hillary duff's
character um can we expect you in season
two
you know what i think it's sort of
unofficially official that yeah okay it
looked like it was a blast to shoot that
show it's the best uh hillary's a dream
and i just feel lucky to be her friend
i've known her for over 10 years and um
and it's just the the entire group there
all the actors the the creators it's a
beautiful time and yeah i i feel so
lucky to be a part of it and you and
hillary share co-star now peter herman
right because he was in younger with her
have you met this people i have not he's
dreaming he looks dreamy on screen he's
like six five like he's a giant man so
handsome so handsome so lovely yeah like
when we first met he's like can you tell
me about tick-tock i was like peter
really i love this dad moment wow
moving some things around
and like we talked about our kids and
you know he's just he's a beautiful guy
i'm saying hillary get him on to how i
met your father seems right too i think
that'd be awesome yeah i'd love it find
a way to do it find a way to do it when
you tell the story in the future just
promise me you will change that part i
love it uh so we were just talking about
fatherhood you're expecting baby number
two i mean are you ready to expand the
brood like how's the house looking right
now i like the great elon musk i am
repopulating the earth you know i'm here
and this is my contra you're welcome
thank you so much
thank you so much so tell me this if one
day your kids say i want to pursue
acting no matter what age they are
what's your reaction going to be you
know i always say that i'll give them
all the support to take acting class and
do school plays and all the great things
you can do as a kid and then when
they're 18 if they decide they want to
sort of follow it into college or what
have you i'll have them major in finance
you're like dude follow the money it's
not happening right
no you know what the truth is is i think
it's something that you can really you
don't necessarily have to do
professionally as a kid
and then eventually if he he follows his
passion and he loves it then then i'll
support him because i think that's
really important well he's got a great
teacher in you so i'm excited to see
what he decides to do i feel like you're
going to support him no matter what he
decides he's like oh you want to be an
engineer cool yeah we got you oh my gosh
that would be the best well thank you so
much we appreciate your time and 13 the
musical is streaming now on netflix
[Music]
you